[Music]
spiritually fit what does that mean to
you well
spiritually fit means i'm in my body
paradoxically
it doesn't mean i'm in some ether world
of you know divine enlightenment and it
means i heard a preacher years ago
say the 23rd psalm which is the lord is
my shepherd i shall not want
but she said the lord is my shepherd i
shall not trip
and i just love that because when i'm
spiritually not fit i'm just
tripping you know i'm making up stories
i'm in fear i'm in anxiety i have i have
a tremendous anxiety disorder for which
i'm successfully treated most of the
time but i'm just tripping on something
somebody said that it's stuck in my craw
on something i'm afraid of of something
a lot of fear in recovery there's some
great acronyms for fear
because people like my coke head friends
i mean i'm my own cokehead friend but
they would say that the false evidence
appearing real which usually means that
you're at the window peering through the
drapes thinking that there are there's a
swat team on your lawn at four in the
morning you know and that the only the
best idea you have is another cool
refreshing beer but some of the ones i
love is one is the frantic effort to
appear recovered that's my main thing is
that when i need to look good when i
need to appear to be doing well is when
i'm at my most spiritually
lost and another one i love is future
events already ruined and so i'm just
tripping out like i was tripping out
this morning about what if i screwed up
with tim you know and and you're so
illustrious and your
listenership i think is younger and why
would they want this old lady with
dreadlocks as sunday school teacher
where do our zen diagrams meet and i was
tripping and then i remembered you know
future events already ruined that's not
true that's just k-fuck radio and
another one i love is fear expressed
allows
relief and so i told hill and he said
you know you you are so wonderful at
this just breathe and go for a walk
first and do what you do and you'll be
sitting there with sam and tim is great
and you're gonna love it it's gonna go
by so quickly but so fear express allows
relief so
spiritually fit for me is that i'm not
tripping and that i'm breathing
when i was a child i didn't breathe you
know i held my breath because for all
the reasons i told you and i remember i
used to pass out on the boardwalk in
town
at three years old and my dad would
nudge me and say annie annie and i blink
awake but if you breathe
you may end up in your body and it may
be that in your body terrible things
happen to you and if you're a girl
addict an alcoholic like i am you know
until
1986 you let terrible things happen in
your body you encourage terrible things
if you let people do anything at all
that they want they seem to like you
better briefly you know and so breathing
will bring you into your body so for
that reason
you may resist it but for me to do what
i call the sacrament of ploppage and to
sit down and for one minute
to breathe into my heart cave
ah and do the do the sighing
i get my sense of humor back you know
and laughter
even at my own
quirky fearful darling self laughter
i've written in a number of places is
carbonated holiness so if i'm breathing
and i've gotten my sense of humor back
i'm in something spiritual i'm something
that has to do with my human spirit
and the divine i mean i believe and and
i've i've heard that we have dual
citizenship you know we're we're
children of the divine or children of
sons and daughters of god and we also
have these
kind of screwed up biographical
details we've got genetic details that
we would have maybe not preferred we
have predispositions to alcoholism and
mental illness or to weight gain in our
thighs or whatever but i have to
remember that i can toggle back between
dual citizenship
between
being a child of god or of the
great universal spirit and annie lamont
67
sunday school teacher and left-wing
activist mother and grandmother and you
know i got married at 65. i got married
three days after i got medicare and
those are my true biographical details
and i also am a person of spirit
so that's what spiritually fit means for
me is that i remember that i'm not this
terrible pinball machine in my mind
cranking out new ideas about how i can
do life more perfectly so that everybody
will think more highly of me
you